[Music]
high-conflict personalities or people
with those and i refer to them as HCPs
have four key characteristics that make
some of them want to be political
leaders they love to blame other people
they're preoccupied with other people's
behavior there's a lot of all-or-nothing
thinking and for politicians it's
all-or-nothing solutions to problems
they have unmanaged emotions or intense
emotions and they actually shift
everything to the emotional side which
helps give them power but lastly they
have extreme behaviors behaviors that
ninety percent of people would never
have maybe even 99 percent of people
when they become high conflict
politicians human beings like to be
independent they like to do things their
own way but when there's a crisis
they'll follow a leader and so when a
high conflict personality wants to
become a leader first of all they don't
have good problem-solving skills and
they don't have good leadership skills
so what happens is to become a leader
they have to create a crisis or just say
something as a crisis say there's an
evil villain over there related to this
or caused the crisis and I'm a hero
and if people identify them with the
image of a strong man an image of the
hero then they will follow that person
but wait a minute there isn't really a
crisis and this person isn't really a
hero and there isn't really a villain in
general the world is much better off
than it's ever been there's less hunger
people live longer all of this but the
message that grabs our attention is
crisis fear conflict chaos and so we're
fed that in many ways because we want to
be fed that we're shifting from reading
the news and talking about it in a
matter-of-fact manner to high emotions
its faces it's voices it grabs your
attention
and it's kind of like constant
advertising you don't even have to think
your brain absorbs this information so
we see all these leaders around the
world the ones who are the most high
conflict personality are the ones who
come forward in this face and voice news
environment and they grab your attention
they grab your brain and they make up
stories it doesn't matter if they're
true or false it's the best stories and
the modern media inadvertently I think
is really promoting these people who
would have just stayed on the fringes
who everyone would have laughed at and
said you know you're just way out of
line here high-conflict politicians
always have a love-hate relationship
with the media and the reason for this
is they love the attention but they
don't like or they hate the
interpretation and so they want to fight
the interpretation what that helps with
the drama because if they're in conflict
if they say well you your reporters can
attend my event only these reporters can
that's more conflict that's more chaos
more crisis more fear people are afraid
oh if I step on this person's toes we
won't get to have our reporter there so
it just adds to the drama but the key
thing that happens is the media repeats
the emotional messages of the high
conflict politician and that just sails
on through and that's what gets into our
brain without even thinking like
advertising emotional repetition is the
key to how high-conflict politicians
communicate with and excite everybody
they excite their followers but they
also make their opponents angry and
ineffective as they get emotionally
hooked and fight with each other the
parts of our brain that are paying
attention to the most to human emotions
are the relationship parts of our brain
and so they can form a relationship with
people by doing this at an emotional
level without really thinking and in
many ways it's a seduction process
yes just like a conman would seduce a
woman that they want their credit card
or they want to marry them and then
spend their money on the next person
they say all these emotional things
you're wonderful you're beautiful you're
the best thing that ever happened to me
and high-conflict politicians have
you're wonderful we agree with each
other we're the best thing for each
other when in fact it's all calculated
[Music]